Ake, how you doing, bro? I'm good, man.
I'm good. Good, good, good. You got a
verse in chapter 3 that says the Quran
that the Bible's corrupted or that only
parts of it is true. Anything like that
in chapter 3? In chapter 3 of the Quran?
Yeah. I mean, I think it's pretty
understood, you know, that as far as the
Muslims believe, you know, we we hold to
the fact that the Bible, we do believe
that there's some remnants of truth in
it, but it can't be taken completely as
the word of God as it. Where does it say
that? I mean, come on, man. I don't
understand why we were even arguing. It
says it why why are we even doing this?
Giant giant dosa. Didn't you have like
um a slide with 18 different times where
the Arabic word for confirmed talking
about how the Quran confirms the Torah
in the Injil? That's right. We do. We'll
bring it for you. So, we'll tell you why
is because Muslims love to spread these
beliefs that are not actually in their
religion. One of them is that uh we
can't trust the whole Bible. But the
Quran is full of verses that use that
word which means confirming. You know
from the word which means truth and even
other verses like surah 2 vers 85 where
it says you can't just believe in some
of the Torah and leave the rest. You
have to believe in all of it. And in
other verses of the Quran in surah 5
where it says judge by the gospel and
judge by the Torah that you have in your
hands at the time of Muhammad. So
everything we got context, what was the
context of that particular that last one
you just brought up when he said judge
according to the gospel or the Torah?
Well, the the Torah is surah 5:43.
Yeah. Do you remember? Do you know the
content? Cuz you guys really I
do you guys like I'm saying what was
happening at the time when Yeah. They
probably they probably don't even know.
They probably don't even know. Yeah.
It's not it's not like we just
translated like three commentaries on it
just today alone. We went we went to
your commentaries. Okay. So the
question quick refresher what what was
happening yeah refresh us all. Yeah.
Okay. So what happened was Muhammad she
already sounds nervous. Some some of the
Jews went to him to get a judgment on a
problem they had. Allah said to them why
do you come to Muhammad when you have
the Torah that has my judgment in it?
Okay. Okay. You know what? She she
happened to know that one but ask her
next time. She going to go to the next
one. That that's good. And then so
knowing that context and knowing exactly
what they were asking about and and what
were they asking for a ruling on? Do you
remember what they were asking for?
Adultery. Oh, okay. So that's simple.
And then and today doesn't you still
have something to the remnant of, you
know, stoning or something. Correct. So
that actually proves our point. Whatever
was in the Torah at Muhammad's time that
Allah loved and said that's my judgment,
we have it today. So how do you so from
the so from the paradigm of the Muslims
guys do you agree that as far as the
Quran says the the Torah and the NGL are
not what they were that's what we need
you for our friend that's what we need
you for show us that reference that says
that it's changed it's been corrupted
happened to it all the Quran says is
that all the Quran says is that the
people of the book they misinterpret
things they hide things they're bad
they're basically bad people but the
book is ace The book is preserved. The
book is So the Quran says the book is
perfectly preserved. Yes. 100%. So what
is what is Muayan over?
Nice.
Good.ard. Which in the commentaries do
you want? Because there's about six or
seven definition. Forget forget the
commentaries. Let's just What does that
word mean? Just the definition of an
Arabic guardian. We're telling you that
Arabic scholars give you about eight
different definitions for it. So which
one do you want? What do you think it
means? What is the what is the general
consensus of the paradigm in Islam? What
that means?
It means confirmer or guardian. Okay. So
if it needs to be a guardian, why would
it need to be the guardian? Allah Allah
is a guardian over the Quran to to keep
a guardian over the Quran. But he said
the Quran is Muhammad over the the book
the Torah and be in jail. So what would
that why do you think that mean? What do
you think that
mean? Akeim, think about the think about
the context cuz we just brought up 543
and 547. 543 tells the Jews, why you
coming to Muhammad for judgment when you
have the Torah? Then a few verses later,
Christians, you judge by the gospel. If
you don't, you're you're you're no
better than those who rebel. You're in
rebellion, right? And then the next
verse says, the Quran is the guardian
over the previous scriptures. In
context, what does that mean? It means
there are Jews who are trying to get
away from judging by the Torah, and the
Quran says, "No, no, no, you don't.
You're not going around. You're not
going to someone else. You're not even
going to Muhammad. You are going right
back to your book. Few verses later,
Christians, what are you supposed to
judge by? Do not look outside your book.
You go right back to your book. And then
very next verse, Quran is the guardian
over the previous scriptures. What does
it mean for the Quran to guard the
previous scriptures? In context, it
means when there are Jews who try to
avoid the Torah, the Quran sends them
right back. When Christians try to avoid
the gospel, the Quran sends them right
back. In other words, the Quran claims
to do the exact opposite of what Muslims
do with the Torah and the Gospel. They
say, "Jews, don't go with the Torah, go
with the Quran. Christians, don't don't
go with the Gospel, go with the Quran."
They're saying the exact opposite. And
so, the Quran is guarding the previous
scriptures, not only from Jews and
Christians who don't want to follow
them, but also from Muslims who want to
deny them and want and want Jews and
Christians to reject them. So, so Allah
is guarding the previous scriptures from
you and your shake and your imam and
everyone else who wants to uh who wants
to deny them. Okay, you're entitled to
your opinion. That's obviously that's
what Allah says. That's Allah. That's
Allah. I'm telling you what Allah just
said. Give me one word that I just said
that that is not directly from that
text. What did I say? Beautifully
executed. I love No, that was not
beautifully executed. What part of what
I just said it did I not get directly
from the text? Because that's not the
Quran does not say that the the Torah
that we have that the the Jews and the
Christians had is perfect and perfectly
preserved. It there no
Muslim no commentary no commentary that
says that the Torah is do this do this
for us who he just said no commentary no
commentary said no commentary on the
screen I got a commentary for you. Do
you know who I is? Do you know who I
Okay. And when when did I even kir live?
You said there's no commentary to say
that the Torah, the Old Testament, the
New Testament, which you guys been
talking about all day, is is now you're
waffling. No, no, but you can't say
that. Let's look at Let's look what the
commentary says. Okay. Al Bkari reported
that Abbas said that this ayah means
that the alter and ad although none none
amongst Allah's creation can remove the
words of Allah from his books they alter
and distort their apparent meanings.
They cannot they cannot change Allah's
words. Um, well, J, you're lying. That's
There is no There is no commentary that
says I've
already I've heard a commentary about
this that the words of Allah cannot be
changed. Listen to this. The Torah and
the Injil remain as Allah revealed them,
and no letter in them was removed. Boom.
[Music]
And then it says they are preserved and
cannot be changed. Okay. So there's one
book that exists that was No, no, please
let me finish. There's one book that was
sent down from Allah that's not been
changed. What you're claiming? Wait,
Akeim, just just really quick. Can you
affirm now he showed you the comments at
least two here? We got Abbas and we got
Wabin Munabi. Both of them say that the
books of Allah remain as Allah revealed
and they're unchanged. Correct? That's
what it says. That's what Okay, so just
really quick, look, it's on the screen,
bro. Iban Abbas said that they alter and
add although none among Allah's creation
can remove the words from Allah's books.
They
only apparent meanings. Right. Where's
the book then? We'll get to that in a
second. Hold on. Yeah, we we'll get
we'll get to where are they in a second.
Can we can you just acknowledge that
says that they're perfectly preserved?
Right. I do not believe that that's what
they're saying because where are the
books? It's in front of you, dude. The
book the books that on my
bookshelf guys I'm saying the logic guys
come on the logic in what you're saying
is then that means there should be some
book somewhere where is
only hey if only my fellow Christians if
there was an example of some Torah and
gospel out there that Christians have
maybe been using maybe even before
Muhammad's time maybe for like maybe
like I don't know 2,000 years or so if
only there was a book out there that
that that that that we had that that
that we was reading that we was using to
represent the scriptures. Oh, only if
only if only. But but you only but you
definitely it's a it's an accepted thing
that there's too many variants. But hold
on, I now you're switching. You're going
to
be noting because you're
saying realize you said there's no
commentary and there's no
commentary commentaries and then you
deny what's on the screen. Why do you
deny what's on the screen? Because
you're used to doing that that with the
Quran. When Allah says Jews don't need
Muhammad because they have the Torah,
you say, "No, stop lying, Allah." When
the Quran says Jews have to that
Christians have to judge by the gospel,
you say, "Stop lying, Allah. That's not
what they're supposed to judge by. They
don't have that." In 568 in 568, Allah
says that the people of the book, Jews
and Christians, have no ground to stand
upon unless they stand fast by the
Torah, the gospel, and all the
revelation has come to them. You're
saying, "Stop lying, Allah. They don't
have either one of those." That would if
Allah, if you're speaking the truth,
that would mean they have them. But that
makes no sense cuz I've decided based on
what my da guys say that they don't have
it. You have a man- centered religion.
You worship your da'wah guys, not Allah.
Allah is very clear. This is Allah is
more clear about the about the the
preservation of the previous scriptures
than he is on any other issue in the
Quran and you guys deny it. Why? Because
your dawa guys told you something else
and you side with them. Muhammad says
Muhammad said that if Allah says
something and you listen to a man tell
you something different, you're
worshiping that man. So congratulations.
Modern Islam is the biggest bunch of
mushriicks I've ever seen. Let's Let's
test this out. Let's test this out. Ake,
I'mma give you another chance, man, to
stay on here and engage. If you can't be
honest, then I'm going to move on to the
next person. Dude, I'm This is what
According to. All right, so now I got to
just muzzle you cuz you're just barking.
According to what is on the page, Ake,
are there two commentaries here? That's
matter. Let's just keep it simple. Okay.
What? It says right here, you see it
highlighted in green. Thumbs up if you
see it. Thumbs up if you see it in
green. Okay. In the green, does it say
the Torah and the Inil remain as Allah
revealed them and no letter has been
removed from them? Does it say that? Can
you finish the next sentence after? Get
out of here, y'all. Get out of here.
You're a bum. Yeah. The next Yeah. The
next sentence gives the st gives what
the Quran actually says. People Yeah.
People misguide false interpretations
relying on books they wrote themselves.
What do they do? So they'll take a verse
and then they'll keep talking about it
and change the meaning. It's it's it's
what it's exactly what you find in surah
3:78. They distort it with their
tongues. Yeah. And so that's actually
what what it goes on to quote. It says,
"This is from Allah, but it's not from
Allah." Then it says, "As for Allah's
books, they're still preserved and they
cannot be changed." And then it says
that the for example the Arabic versions
of these books they might be erroneous
or have errors or whatever but the books
themselves the last sentence there these
books are preserved and were never
changed were never changed. Nah that's
that's not that top been corrupted.
One of the weapons is I have another one
as well cuz he said no commentary says I
have another one as well. Prove it.
Prove it. Show the other one. You ain't
got Let's just do this one for fun.
Let's just do this one for fun.
Ain't no way, man. There's not there's
not going to be two. There's not be two
that say it. There wasn't even one. He
said, "All right." So So this is book.
Okay. And
I And wait, I'm sorry. DLC. Who is Ibam?
Okay. Well, he's a Muslim for a star.
For a start, he's a Muslim. He's a Okay.
Uh who's the student of who? Uh he's a
he's a student of IMEA. I may so a
student of Imita someone who's a student
next to Ibath. So this is who this guy
is, right? He's right there with Ibath.
Both of them were students of Imitus.
This is why it's important knowing who I
is. So Ibekam student of Imita side by
side with Ibath. And what does he talk
about guys? So he quotes the hadith
where Muhammad puts the Torah on a
cushion and he says I believe in you and
he revealed you. So he says that this
there's a group of scholars who say
based on that hadith they say that if
something was substituted and changed
then he wouldn't have placed it on the
cushion and he wouldn't have said I
believe in you and he revealed you. And
then he asked for interpretation. What's
the interpretation of chapter 6 verse
115? They they quote the verse that none
can alter the words of Allah. He is
hearing the knowing. And they said, "And
his Torah, the Torah is from his words."
Wait, hold up. I'm a little lost because
Muslims today, giant, Chris, David, they
tell me that that hadith is weak, right?
That's what they say. Is it? So you mean
to tell me that there's Muslim groups
way before all these guys who was using
this hadith as evidence for the
preservation of previous scriptures
before us? Yeah. And by the way Kafir
quotes it too. It ali says it's
authentic. Abu D there's something
called silence is consent in Islam. Abu
D had a rule. The rule was if he doesn't
comment on it it's valid. So Bi said
it's Abu
Du. And then you have this whole group
of scholars that's by student who say
that actually based on that hadith which
is because it's authentic none can
change Allah's word. So they interpreted
he has for a commentary chapter 615 to
be that the Torah is from his words
therefore it can never be changed and
and by by the way think about that um
their quote for everyone who's watching
you need these are these are two
references you need to jot down. So 6115
actually include the verse before
because it gives the context to show
that it's talking about Allah's revealed
written word. So 614 to 615 and then 18
surah 18 verse 27 they both say the same
thing speaking in the context of Allah's
revealed written word. It says there is
none who can change his words. So recite
what has been revealed to you the book.
There is none who can change his words.
And then Muslims will have to do what?
They'll have to say no, he means no one
can change his words in the Quran, which
isn't what it says. It says no one can
change his words. So what happens? They
add words to the Quran, which is what
the Quran condemns Jews and Christians
for doing with their scriptures. They
have to add words to change the meaning.
Why? Because if you don't add those
words, you get mus later Muslims doing
exactly what you see here. No one can
change any of the Allah's books because
he specifically says in 615, no one can
change his words. So this is the this is
like example 487 from the Quran itself
of the Quran saying one thing and
Muslims today saying the exact opposite
of what Allah says. Why? Because they
listen to their dawa guys, not to the
Quran. What does Allah say? Muslims,
what does he say? There is none who can
change his words. The reason you're
supposed to trust his book is because
there is none who can change his words.
Let me ask Muslims, is there anyone who
can change Allah's words? Yes, of course
there is. Anyone, any idiot walking down
the street can change Allah's words. The
Jews did it. The Christians did it.
Everyone did it with every He Allah
Allah is the worst preserver of the of
his books in history. Anyone can change
his So think about this. Allah says no
one can change his words. Muslims say
anyone can change his words. They're
they're saying the exact opposite and
they don't care. And you could get a
thousand Muslims on with us right now.
And we would all and we would say we
could say to every one of them, "Allah
says no one can change his words. Your
da'wah guy says his words have been
changed over and over again. Who do you
who do you believe?" 1,000 out of 1,000
of them will go with their da guys cuz
that's who they worship.